la visita de joe biden a europa
simboliza el regreso de eeuu al
multilateralismo
en su primer viaje oficial al extranjero
el presidente estadounidense pretende
revertir la posición de américa first de
su predecesor donald trump y sustituirla
por el américa is back en su encuentro
el jueves con el primer ministro
británico boris johnson ambos
mandatarios reeditaron la carta del
atlántico actualizando la colaboración
entre los dos países frente a los retos
del siglo 21 con el cambio climático a
la cabeza y frente a las potencias rusa
y china un sello previo al inicio del g7
donde las siete potencias abordan la
salida global de la pandemia con las
discusiones sobre las donaciones de
vacunas y la posible liberalización de
las patentes encima de la mesa después
de cornualles baiden se dirigirá a
bruselas para reunirse con los líderes
de la otan donde deberá paliar las
relaciones pensadas por trump así como
por su propio anuncio de la retirada de
las tropas de afganistán
el martes va a ir en celebrará la
primera cumbre entre eeuu y la unión
europea desde 2014 ambas potencias
prevén abordar entre otros temas la
batalla de aranceles lanzada por trump
un encuentro con el telón de fondo de la
problemática alrededor de los puestos
aduaneros en el mar de irlanda en el
contexto post break sheet una cuestión
en la que tanto la unión europea como
reino unido quieren tener washington a
su favor ni la última parada es la que
genera más expectación la cita con el
presidente ruso vladimir putin en suiza
el próximo jueves
joe biden pretende plantear temas que ya
han generado tensiones previas al
encuentro las maniobras militares rusas
en la frontera con ucrania así como el
encarcelamiento de alexéi navalni y la
persecución de la oposición rusa